Now that we understand a little bit more about the basics of Niagara liquids, including enabling
the plugin and how Niagara liquids are built based out of multiple modules, let's take
a look at creating some Niagara liquid effects now by creating some 2D smoke, liquid and fire
effects.
For this example, we're going to be first starting off creating some 2D liquid, but the steps
that we're going to be using can be applied to the smoke, liquid or fire depending on what
you are doing.
To do this, what we're going to do is right click inside of the content browser, select
Niagara system, and then from the create Niagara system dialog box that comes up, we are going
to go over here to Niagara fluids.
Now if we click on Niagara fluids, just the main folder is going to show us every single
thing that's inside of here, which is good if you want to see everything that is available.
We are going to expose the folder, we're going to uncollapse it so that we can see
the 2D gas, 2D liquid, 3D gas, 3D liquid, grid utility and shallow water, and then click
on our 2D liquid and select the grid 2D flip hose.
So let's go ahead and pop over here to the editor.
We're going to right click inside of here, go to Niagara system, and I'm already there,
but we can click on this.
So there's our Niagara fluids.
We're going to click down here to our 2D liquid.
I'm going to select this grid flip hose and hit create.
I'm going to call this NS underscore 2D liquid.
All right.
Now before I open it up, there's a couple of things that I want to talk about.
Now when you first click on your Niagara system and you open it up, one of the things to make
note of is that liquid smoke and fire simulations are extraordinarily complex and they are built
out of multiple modules.
While we're starting off with one that's relatively simple, you're going to see here in a few
examples they start to build in complexity and in order to cut down on the amount of settings
that you have to mess with or look for, there's this thing called an Admitter Summary.
And the Admitter Summary is used to highlight some of the most useful properties that are
available to work with this particular system.
So when we click on the Admitter and we go to the Details panel, we're going to see something
that looks like this, the Admitter Summary here.
It's got some different categories, SIM, grid, collisions and all.
It's going to be different based on the liquid that you have selected.
And then there's all these properties in here that are, again, the properties that you are
going to use to adjust this are the most common properties.
Now if you want to expose more to the Admitter, you can still do that.
All you got to do is just hit this little triangle right here.
And what that's going to do is it's going to un-collapse the Admitter stack right here
and we're going to see an Admitter that looks at something similar to what we are used to.
So let's just take a look at that now.
So I'm going to double click on my 2D liquid to open it up.
Let's just expand this.
And then right here, if I click on it, you can see here on my Details panel, I have just
the properties I'm going to find super useful, like for example, number of cells max axis.
This is how we control the resolution of this.
So increasing this number is going to make the water have a higher resolution to work
with.
It's going to make it more realistic and things like that.
Lowering this is going to make it run a little faster and look a little blockier.
For us, what I want you to do now is just expose the other properties of our Admitter,
again, just by hitting this little drop down here to un-collapse and re-collapse.
And now once it's un-collapsed, we can see all of the properties.
What we're going to be doing is we're going to go to Particle Spawn and then we're going
to adjust the Lifetime and then the Spawn Radius and the Offset.
And this is going to basically make the particles take a little bit less time to die off.
Move the Spawn Radius down.
We're going to move the Offset way far back.
So let's just take a look at that now.
So make more sense once we do this.
So we're going to, again, come to our Particle Spawn Lifetime.
We're going to set this to a value of 3.
And you can see here what it's going to do is those particles are just going to die off
a lot sooner than they normally would.
Sphear Radius, I'm going to set this to 100.
It's just going to give us a little bit of a larger area to have things admit.
And then right here in the Offset, what we're going to do is I'm going to go negative 900.
And that should push this up and it pushed a little bit too far out of our volume.
So that is okay.
What we're going to do here is we're going to come back to this and we're going to go
down to our World Grid Extents right here.
We're just going to set this to 2048.
And there we go.
So the World Grid Extents will come to that in the next slide, but that's going to basically
work as our boundary for our particle system.
So let's go ahead and just pop back over here.
Now what we're going to do is we're going to re-collapse everything and we're going to enable
the Use Depth Map Collisions.
This is going to set it up so that the particles will react to collisions that have been placed
into the world via static meshes or skeletal meshes.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to come back over here to the editor.
We are going to, remember, collapse this and now we have this available.
So the other thing we're going to do here is we're going to go Use Depth Map Collisions.
And then we've already done this, but the World Grid Extents here, we want to set that
to 2048, which is going to push this thing out.
Let's do one other thing here.
We're going to come back to this.
Let's go to our particle spawn real quick.
And let's go ahead and set this offset to like 300.
Yeah, that looks about good.
So remember to pile and save.
And what's going to happen now is when we place this into the world like so, we are going
to be able to have it not only collide with the world, but also objects that we have manipulated
in the world.
So let's check that out.
All right.
So I'm going to close this down.
I'm going to hit Control Space and just drag my particle into the world here.
And there we go.
I'm going to just move it on over a little bit and then watch this.
Soon as I put this up, boom, got it ramping right off there.
So that's really working right out of the gate with everything set up and ready to go.
Now the next thing that we're going to take a look at is creating a smoke and fire effect
kind of getting smoke and fire in the same one because actually smoke and fire are kind
of the same thing.
You can't have smoke without a fire source or something like that or so I'm told.
So let's go ahead and create this new one.
So I'm actually going to delete this out of the scene.
Whenever you're dealing with any types of liquids, you want to make sure that your scene
stays as clean as possible for performance sake.
So I'm going to hit Control Space and then we're going to right click Niagara System.
And then this time from Niagara fluids, we're going to go to a 2D gas and we want this 2D
gas moving fire.
We're going to hit create and then we're going to call this NS underscore 2D fire gas.
And let's go ahead and double click on it to open it up.
Now when we open this up, we're going to see things that look a little bit different.
First off, we're going to have a new node here, which is going to look like this and
it's going to be similar to our source particles node.
But this additional node, what this is actually taking care of is all of the information from
the fluid sim is going to happen inside of this node.
We're also going to have our Niagara overview node, which is going to allow us to add things
like user parameters and other interesting bits that we want to expose when this is either
added to a world or it's spawned through blueprints and then our source particles.
So again, it works like this.
Our source particles are how we are going to shape our particles as they move through
the world.
We might want to skin them to something within the world or we might want to have them admit
from something.
All of that's going to happen here in our source particles.
Then once those particles have been spawned, we're going to take the information from this
grid 2D gas smoke simulation and skin that to those particles locations, giving us a
the illusion that this really complicated fluid simulation is happening.
But where in reality, what's really going on is we're running this Niagara SIM and then
we're putting the fluid simulation on top of that.
And the reason we do it in this manner is it allows us full control over where the particles
are going.
And as the particles move, we apply that fluid simulation.
So again, we don't have to worry about making the fluid simulation go in that direction.
It will go in that direction because it's attached to the particles that are already
headed that way.
So let's go ahead and just pop into the editor here real quick and have a look at our 2D
fire.
So there's our 2D fire effect.
Again, we have our source here and then our fluid simulation.
And notice that the fluid simulation is set into the Admitter Summary.
If I was to expose this, you're going to see here it is a very, very, very complex system.
There's all types of different pressure solves and compute shaders and things like that.
But using it just like this will allow me to see the properties that I'm going to use
most often.
Again, our Admitter Summary right up here at the top, we can also edit this by clicking
on Admitter Summary and then adjusting the things that are inside of here.
As for what the Admitter Summary is going to contain, well, each one is going to be
broken down into a different area.
Each liquid is going to also be slightly different.
So you might find some of these and you might not find some of these.
So simulation is going to be dealing with how the simulation changes over time.
Forces is, I'm sorry, sources is going to be adjusting source parameters to control information
based off incoming particles.
Our forces is going to affect on properties like density, temperature, buoyancy.
Collisions will deal with how this will collide with the world, other and other effects.
And then finally, our renderer is how this will work with rendering and lighting.
So again, it's all been set up to work in a way that makes it easier to kind of digest
each one of the parameters.
Now, one of the other things to note about this, since we are simulating how smoke and
fire work, which is our natural phenomena, we don't need to adjust that many parameters
to get something that looks realistic or something that behaves in a realistic manner, but still
is artistically driven.
So oftentimes it just comes down to simply maybe changing something like the temperature
to like 0.1 or 0.5 or, you know, if I set it to 2, it gets extraordinarily hot.
So maybe I have this temperature multiplier, maybe it's something that I have exposed
so that I can scale it over time.
So it starts at 0.1 and then goes to 2 and 3 and 4 and 5 and 6 and so on, and will increase
over time.
There isn't a magic property in here that's also going to make your fire look better or
more realistic.
What is going to help give you the most realistic options are very subtle changes in your numbers.
I'm talking like, you know, maybe I set this to 5 to see what happens, maybe set it to
1, but doing something like maybe 100 or 500, these are all going to give you values that
don't really look that realistic.
So just be careful when doing things like that.
Now, the next thing that I want to talk about is collision.
So your 2D and your 3D particles will all collide with objects that have placed in the
world.
We saw that with the water.
Now, one thing to note, if you're using an older version of Unreal or for some reason
things are not working, check that the object that you wish to collide with your effect.
So in this case here, we have this static mesh that we want to collide and the actor
tags, we put this tag collider all lowercase c-o-l-l-i-d-e-r that will make this object
collide with your smoke effects.
Now the reason that I bring this up is in Unreal 5.6, apparently you do not need to do this
anymore.
So let me show you what I'm talking about.
We're going to come here.
I'm going to re-rotate that.
We're going to go to add geometry, not geometry, I'm sorry, shapes.
I'm going to add a cube here and just move this cube over and down.
And then we're going to grab our gas 2D, put that in here and check this out.
If I bring this over like so, it's kind of cool.
It makes it almost like I'm dampening the fire here.
And it's actually blocking it.
The reason it comes through from the top is because we're using the depth to block it.
And from this particular viewpoint, my depth information is signifying there isn't anything
up there.
That's why it's working in this view.
But you can see here, I can block half of the smoke.
And again, if that's not working, just come here, look for your tag, add a tag called
Collider.
And you should see the exact same results.
And again, this is going to work with any static mesh that you have.
It will also work with the...
Let me just actually move that out of the way because I can't move the player with that,
but it's also going to work with the player as well.
Let's look at that right out of the box.
It's working.
You can see here, the player is kind of disrupting the gas of...or I should say the smoke of the
fire.
And it's actually very, very cool.
And it gets even cooler when we add a 3D effect to it.
So that is going to wrap up our 2D section.
We're going to look next at creating 3D versions of our smoke and fire in the next part of
this tutorial.